[Music]
all right hello everybody i'm
grandmaster robert hungaski
and i'm here to talk to you about some
more end games and
today we're going to pick up where we
left off last week
so last week we discussed the philidor
position
of the bishop and rook against
rook end game and at the end of that
media video i
made a brief introduction
to the end game that we're going to be
discussing today which is
rook and h-pawn against bishop which
seems like such an
overwhelming material advantage that it
should be a slam dunk for the side with
the extra pawn
and exchange but it actually is not so
easy
i remember the first time i got around
to thinking about this
end game it was almost 10 years ago
i was playing an open tournament in
barcelona
and uh sam shankland was playing in that
same tournament and we were
both saying at the same
hotel or youth hostel that was maybe
like 10 blocks away from the tournament
hall
so every day we would walk back and
forth to and from the tournament
and we'd talk a little bit about the
games or or whatever
and i think it was in round five that
sam played this game
and i don't know if it was walking back
to the hotel or the next day
walking to the round he told me you know
that's actually a very interesting end
game
you should check it out it's not as easy
as it looks
because he ended up with the bishop and
he drew it and i was i remember i was
watching that and
damn sam you got lucky you were down on
a pawn in exchange he's like dude that's
like a really famous end game and i had
no idea
and he said you should check out
your malinsky's video on it and
i don't know if you if any of you have
ever heard of your malinsky's
radio show on icc called
every russian schoolboy knows it's a
great
uh it's a great show and uh
one of my favorite videos i mean they're
all really good
one of my favorite is the one where he
deals with that end game
so after sam told me that i went i went
you know
home i checked it out i studied it and i
was blown away i'm like oh this end game
is so interesting but it's
so hard to really wrap your head around
and especially to to play it well
when when you have it in front of you so
[Music]
you know sam told me about that and i
always kept that video i
i entered it into chess base i put my
own analysis there
and then another great resource that i
found that also dealt with that end game
is yuri our box comprehensive chess end
games
so i've actually quoted it here in the
text of the game it's probably one of
the
greatest end game resources out there in
terms of reference material there are
other books that do a lot more you know
uh
explanation with words but averbach is
really a great uh
a great place just to see what the
winning method is and then you can put
your own words
to it so that's another great place
to look now i'm gonna skip through
most of the moves
and get to the position
that that interests us for today this is
taken directly from
the shanklin game that i was just
talking about
and it's a great place for us to start
now i want to make a a brief correction
because last week when i when i made the
introduction for this video
i was taking something very important
for granted
that's actually very important
and that is that there are two basic
requirements
that you need to understand as black
if you're defending or as white if
you're trying to win i guess
uh to to correctly assess where you're
at
in the end game so in order for white to
be able to win
you need to satisfy two requirements
number one the
black bishop has to be
of the same promoting square as
your pawn in this case that is not
satisfying
um but also your pawn has to be
on the fourth rank or farther back
right now that is satisfied so
i'm sorry if you're defending this you
need to satisfy those two requirements
one is not enough so for example if this
bishop were on g7
or if it were on c3 or b2 this would be
a win for white if
so black has the good bishop now if
white's pawn
were to be advanced to the fifth rank it
would also be a draw so
those are the two things that we need to
know beforehand before we even start
talking about variations
so in order for white to win the pawn
has to be
on the fourth rank period
so white wins in any case if the pawn is
on the fourth
third or second rank first rank i guess
that's not possible so
second third or fourth rank white wins
doesn't matter if you have the good
bishop or the bad bishop
but in order for black to draw you
actually do need this this light square
bishop so okay
now that we got that out of the way any
questions so far because we're gonna
we're gonna build on these
two assumptions and we're going to try
to understand the solution which is
not an easy solution by any means so
i got a little confused so in this
position if the pawns
are not at this position but with that
bishop the pawn on the
fifth rank then it's the drama yes
right so if you're playing with white
it's very easy if your pawn is on the
fourth rank
third or second you win doesn't matter
what bishop your opponent has um
if black has the good bishop which is
this one right
because it runs it's going to cover
these squares while the king covers
these squares
then as white you need to make sure
that your pawn is uh
not advanced beyond the fifth rank right
so okay
uh if if what if black has the bad
bishop your pawn can be on the fifth
sixth rank it doesn't matter you're
gonna win anyway
okay so i'm seeing in the chat that a
lot of people think this end game is a
draw this end game is actually winning
for white
right because if we look at the position
the pawns on the fourth rank boom
that's it and the end of story
so the question is how is white actually
going to win this now
in the game black played king g7 and
after king g5
bishop c2 rookie 7 king g8
and now king h6 so what is
what is the problem that white needs to
overcome why isn't why just why can't
white just push his pawn
and promote like what's what's so
difficult about this endgame
why is it so important for me to keep my
pawn on h4 like if i went h5
and black wastes a tempo and i go h6 and
here
what's the problem it is a draw but
what's the problem
why is it why is it a draw
right you you can't make any forward
progress this bishop
is preventing the pawn from advancing
any further and there's no way to
dislodge
the black king from either the h8 or f7
h7 square so this is a fortress
so what white needs to do is overcome
that fortress
right so first of all we need to take
away these squares from the king
so the first thing that white does is
displace the black king so we want to
get the king
out of the g and h files and onto the f
file
right so now after bishop d3
rook g7 and king f8
so the first part of our goal here is
accomplish the king
is driven from the g h files now why
couldn't the king just go to h8
what could be the problem here
where maybe two where's mate and
to two particular square
d7
okay so rook d7 threatens checkmate and
threatens the bishop all right
so only move bishop c4
now you're going to encounter another
fortress that black has that after you
give check bishop g8
black is threatening stalemate right so
you have to make some kind of retreat
with your rook or with your king to
allow black some kind of move
so this doesn't really seem to make much
progress
and the other option would be
to move the rook to a square where the
that won't allow the bishop to come back
and establish this fortress right so
what
what would that be
f7 and if i go here
right you give check same thing
so this that does not dominate the
bishop we need to dominate this bishop
yes so in the chat we have the move rook
c7
now this prevents bishop c4 as well as
bishop h7
so the only move is to come back with
the king
and now after check king f7
we've also displaced the king
from the g and h files right so we just
need to make sure that this king doesn't
go back so maybe something like this
bishop e4 rook g3 and the king's not
going back
so regardless of whether the king goes
to h8 or f8 we're going to chase it out
of that corner
so that's going to be the first
part of the plan okay so let's see what
actually happened in the game
black played king f8
and now white played h5 so
what do you guys think of this move
any sort
bingo you're absolutely right so
we said at the very beginning of this
end game that there were
two basic premises that we need to
respect
if we want to win this with white number
one
the issue of the bishop that's that's
never going to change once you
you know you establish it in the
beginning it's not like the bishop can
can change diagonals so we can forget
about that
the other important factor is the
placement of this pawn
and why it has to be on the fourth rank
or farther back
because like you just said we
need to do a balancing act between
two separate ideas one is going to be to
keep this king
cut off from the g and h files
and another is going to be to get our
king out of the way of our pawn
because our pawn can promote very easily
with the king on f8 if we just go king
g5 king f6 then
h5 h6 h7 h8 easy peasy
game is over the problem is we can't
get our king out of h6 so easily so
that's going to be step two of the end
game
getting our king out of the h file and
over to the f
file now it's kind of it's kind of like
solving a rubik's cube you're like wait
but
i get this side right but then it messes
up my other side right so
how can you get your king out of h6
without
messing up the cut off king that you've
accomplished on f8
so can anybody come up with an idea as
to how to do that
okay
all right so where where do you want to
put this rook
okay g3 very good and that attacks my
bishop so
i will move my bishop back
and what was your follow-up going to be
king 2.
where do you want to put the king
f6 okay
all right let's say i go here
the problem is that yes you've got your
king over to the sixth rank
and you got your pawn to h6 but in the
process
you let black sneak into h8 right so
um here uh i don't know black can just
go bishop d3 and you can't really make
progress
anymore right for example if rook here
once again bishop here and check and
the idea of stalemate again right if you
just make some random move that's
stalemate so this is the challenge that
we have before us
right so how to keep this king
cut off but at the same time transfer
our king over to the f
file so anybody else want to take a jab
at it
so here in the chat i like i like how
one of the viewers has articulated it
you you cannot advance this pawn
until you have accomplished your idea of
getting the king out of the h file
and over to the f file now this should
give you a hint
as to well then
having the pawn on h4 instead of having
the pawn on h5
must mean that there's a certain square
that's very important for me to
accomplish my goal
now what square could that be
okay so let's let's let's actually go
through it in a variation and see what
kind of problems arises right so
the idea is to use the rook
as a shield and for the king to sneak
behind the rook
that way at the same time you're
preventing black from playing king g8
or king g7 so what you're saying here is
that black can actually stop us from
playing our king g4 move with this check
right but now the king can go to g6
now i'm threatening king f6 winning on
the spot right
so only move for black would be to try
to sneak over
to the g or h file and now
white has a winning move
where does the rook go
rook d5 and if i go
check
right king h6 and now i don't know
because the king is still
still kind of messed up here but what i
could do
is just king f7 and you have to start
all over again
so so unpack that idea you're on to
something
yes bingo so rook c5 so this is going to
be an
important component of white's winning
strategy which is
dominating this bishop that means
preventing this bishop
from reaching its key defensive squares
of h7 and g8 so all of a sudden the
bishop on d1
finds itself offsides right i'm
threatening checkmate so
uh what are you gonna do about that if
you go
king f8 well then i just check you and
after king e7
this is this is a walk in the park i'm
gonna play king g7
h6 h7 whatever so the only move here
is probably bishop g4
right so now that prevents us from
giving our check
i think you could you could push
and yeah this looks like it's going to
be a win
i was actually just looking at well what
if i just try to give you a check in a
different color square right like you
just
you just avoided the problem one more
move
so so i think probably both moves win
but if you play h5
at some point you're gonna have to play
like rook here just to get the king out
of
out of the way right so i think there's
more than one way of winning here and
you can start to tell when the position
is winning when this bishop is
is having a hard time sort of getting
back home
so that's it guys thanks for listening
this is great
uh no no it's going to be so much harder
so much harder than this
so after oops after rook g5
the key is to control this square
before the bishop then the king gets to
h5 that way when we give a check
it can't go to g6 so the key move here
is king to f7 now if you go
king h5 i go bishop e2 check
and you have to go back and then i go
back and you can't make any progress
right so this is
the key position of the end game and i
think now
it's not going to be a spoiler alert as
to why it's so important to have your
pawn on the fourth rank you need this
square
to to maneuver your king out of this
this jam
so after uh
king f7 what do we do how do we make
progress here
and here we're going to use some themes
that we talked about last week when we
discussed the philadelphia end game
maybe
well rook g7 is an interesting move
because the ideal square for the king is
f7
right so this would be
tactical theme we would know as the
in-between move
you you throw in a check to dislocate
your opponent's defenses and then
continue with your own idea
right so for example if king f6 what
would be your
your follow-up
um
oh it's so tempting and i'm going to
show you i'm going to show you you know
i always say
to to students oh don't worry if you
never get this in one of your games
it's not the point and then i actually
got this in one of my games and i was
like oh god
what a nightmare it's actually better
not to get it in one of your games than
to like study it and hope to get it
okay so let's say you you do go h5 uh
and i just waste a move with my bishop
the problem is if you do something like
this you're just going to drive me back
to where i want to go now there's a
there's a much more serious problem for
black here
okay so that attacks the bishop so
if i move the bishop
then i want to play f3 to push that
kingdom
excellent and after here then this is
over
right you're going to push this pawn
very easily now what happens if i
if i block with the bishop
but you've got more than enough time you
can just waste them and now after the
king moves then you can
you can sack and now you you definitely
make it there in time so
definitely on to the right idea now what
if i
say well you're trying to check me and
kick my king out what if i go here
so now if this same deal well not
necessarily right here you still don't
want to take
because black gets there in time but
you could just drop your rook back just
going to go
h5 king d7 anyway so
and if and here here it is the same
thing
so the king can't go to f6 because then
you
you open yourself up to all these
moves that hit your bishop and threaten
to check you and displace your king even
more
so the king always has to drop back
right
now here we can't really play rook g5
because that would just repeat the
position
but this king is going to be one move
away from its perfect square so we need
to find a way
of getting our setup in place
where we can maybe create some threats
and put our rook on g5 and white won't
have
black won't have his dream defensive set
up king on f7
and bishop on either you know d3 or c2
so what can we do here
okay so rook g3 now let's say
black plays bishop b1 just moving the
bishop as far away as possible
all right but don't i just get to play
king f7
ah yes i made him give up too soon
it was just i said it was such
confidence but he was doing a great job
the bishop here is totally misplaced
like the king was misplaced on f8 so
the point is to get both black pieces
misplaced
simultaneously so that when it's black's
move he can only fix one of them
and he won't have enough time and this
that's exactly what's happening here
because now after rook g5 you can get
your bishop back into the game
but not your king and we get to this
position that we've already seen
or you can get your king back into the
game but not your bishop so now i get to
play king g4 because you don't have
the check on d1 or e2
okay so now we see how white is thinking
about this how white is thinking about
overcoming this resistance
now here comes the hard part
it cannot go to b1 the bishop always has
to stay either on the d3
or c2 squares because it needs to be
able to check the king when it gets to
h5
right so the only move for black here is
bishop c2
so what do we do now because if we go
rook g5
then it doesn't seem like we're making
any progress let me just see
how we're doing here
let me just make this the main line
so
let's let me just see where we're at
so anyway right we were talking about uh
rook g3
and now bishop c2
so how do we make progress here
if i go rook g1
then i think you just go king f7
or is there a problem here
so the key of white's victory lies
in forcing a position where this bishop
cannot stay on either c2 or d3
right this is a very dangerous situation
to be in an end game when you arrive at
your utopian
perfect position that's when you're at
your most vulnerable because if it's
your move again
you're you're in big trouble you have to
make you have to make a move that will
undo
your perfect position so
all we need to do is sort of lob the
ball over back in black's court
yes rook g3 so after rook g3
you're saying to black your king looks
great your bishop looks great you have
to move one
right so if you go
king f8 i think that now is this
no no this isn't right wait hold on
am i at the right file
right so we're here uh so
i think rook g1 is one move and after
king f7
okay i see the move we waste
is is rook g1 i think it might work with
rook g3 i think it's the same
idea but the point is
that now right if bishop
here king h5
and now if you go king f7 this is the
position that i want to get to
this is a position when you're in
zugswang
because if you go king f8
can i go
rook g5
yes
if you go king f7 i go king g4
and i get out and if you go check i go
king g6
so that's a zugswang for black
so after rook g3
you can't move your king uh
well can you go king f6 here actually
because if check you still have king g7
what's going on here
king f6 because if i go here
you go back
this king on f6 looks awfully strange
oh i see
there's a nice win for white here
this king is never supposed to be on f6
for good reason
this is this is the king's comfort zone
so what happens when the king steps out
of the comfort zone how can we make sure
it stays there
yes so rook c3
hits the bishop if the bishop i don't
know
tries to stay on this diagonal then we
go rook c7
and now the king is cut off so all we
need to do now is play king h6
and uh and this king is just uh
i think it's just done it's only a
matter of time
when after we get the king to h6 that we
threaten the bishop and we go rook f4
like we saw before right so for example
bishop d3 king h6
bishop e4 then rook c4
and we've seen this before this pattern
right
so the king can't go to f6
either where
so after king f6 rook c3
which checks
h6
okay but remember this is also a factor
right the dominated bishop so you might
get your king to where you want it but
not your bishop so now
i can go uh check for example
you you would probably go here and now
you have no checks
with your bishop because your bishop is
so poorly placed and again we have this
position where
the bishop goes uh to g4 and then you
you can just do something like here and
here
right oh i told you i told you this
would this would be a tough one
i've only been studying it for about 10
years and it's i'm still looking at it
and i'm like
wait what if he does this um
end games you got to tackle them through
layers
right like the first time you take a jab
at an end game just try to get a general
outline of what's going on
you know how how do you win or or draw
like what's
your goal here like if you're playing
with white you obviously want to try to
win this
so what are the situations in which
white wins
right so if you can identify that
no matter what you do you should not
push that pawn beyond the fourth rack
like your idea is to create this bridge
so that your king can get out if if you
go at this end game with that
simple idea even if you mess it up later
and you draw it
at least you'll be building on a solid
foundation and then the more times
you you look at it the the easier it's
gonna
it's gonna become this is by far the
hardest end game i've ever studied
so you know if you're feeling like hey
this is insane
welcome to insane in the end game this
is
uh so
okay so we played rook g3 and it seems
like
uh black is in total swing and this is
uh i don't know if any of you were my
class
last week on the philidor end game where
i told you you need to take a leap of
faith
when when i tell you that you need to
get your opponents rook to c3
right well you need to take a leap of
faith when i tell you that this
is the absolute key position that that
needs to be
uh sort of branded
in your brain knowing that this is how
you win the game game this is the
zugszang position
after this uh black just breaks right so
black's only move here
is again check king g5 and then the
rooks coming to c3
and c7
all right but this is easy so let's make
this a little bit harder
right so after rook g1
black doesn't have to play bishop c2
right because after bishop c2 king h5
king f7
we get our zugzwang position so
let's try to find some other moves for
black besides bishop c2 because
black never wants to put this bishop on
c2 because then that's going to run into
rook g3 so what if black plays king f7
instead
here if you go rook g5 you kind of force
the bishop to c2
but black is able to maintain the the
perfect defense because you don't have
any
way to make further progress here right
if k5
then check so rg5 is not the move that
we want
rook g2 well i think this
i can i can just hit your rook
probably
oops sorry so we're saying king f7
so what would be the other natural part
of white's plan like what
what are the moves that are necessary to
win
besides rook g5
yeah so king h5 has to be a candidate
move
because now with bishop c2 winning
zigzag position right so so like
the first time that i tackled this end
game
i would simply try to to build the
bridge and it wouldn't work
the second time i would know that this
is
the winning position that i need to get
to and i just wouldn't be able to get to
it i would mess something up along the
way
so that's probably where where most
people run into the most trouble because
it's actually the hardest part of this
end game is getting to this position if
black doesn't cooperate
in practice you always get to this
position because it's incredibly hard
for to defend this as black too
black has to know all this stuff it's
not just you
so after king h5 what are the other
options
what about what about king f8
this one's easy
now rook g5 you can't stop
both king uh g4 and king g6
at the same time so you lose what about
king f6
that's right never never should never go
to f6
it's a great rule see because if you
have certain
memory markers or just uh milestones in
the position
that will raise a red flag immediately
you'll you'll know what to look for
so this what's that
rook where oh no
what did you say i did not say
i remember there was this really uh
it was a master he's kind of well liked
by the people that knew him really well
if you didn't know him you would
absolutely hate this person
because he did not like people
chiming in during his lessons uh
for me it's the opposite i think it's
kind of boring if you're the only one
talking
but if you would be showing something
and somebody would yell out
rook g1 you'll be like who said that
who said that he would grab a pencil
and a piece of paper and said what's
your name
you write down your name say i just want
to remember this name because that was
such a brilliant move i've never seen
such a good and it would like lose
immediately right
and uh he would just make you feel so
stupid like you would never you would
never think of
of saying anything ever again uh
and i remember i was kind of a victim of
that a couple of times i was like okay
no thank you so don't don't be afraid if
you made a bad move
i will not i will not take down your
name uh
i know i know how that feels
okay but actually that's that's not so
easy to do
uh right because we can't go rook d1
oh that was your move that was your move
your gasp gave it away because that was
the move i wanted to play
um so the other way
would be to maybe attack it this way
uh another move i would want to play is
maybe here right but then just king f7
and we don't really make much progress
so let's yes attack the bishop
right and where does that bishop go
if you give a check i go here
and i'm very close to to kicking your
king
out to the e file and then it's just
over and if you go
back with the king now what do we do
right which which one of black's pieces
looks a little off
yes right just like we have the dream
squares for the bishop we have the
nightmare
squares for the bishop which are d1 and
e2 it's on the wrong diagonal
so how do we usually dominate a bishop
that's on this
unfortunate diagonal
no no that's always good uh so let's say
the bishop moves
yes right so you could do it here maybe
you could probably do it right away
right the important thing is wherever
your rook goes that it
make sure that these squares are under
control right so c3 does a good job at
both of them
it is a c3 square isn't that something
like every end game
every end game i talk about the c3 score
is incredibly important
um so now you have the bishop
problem again right because check here
and the king here
and uh you're down well maybe no you're
done
no matter where the bishop goes like if
you go here instead of going to b7 i'll
go to d7
oh oh you're just testing you
won good job yeah
please somebody take down my name i'm
ready
i'm ready for the big leagues uh
so
let's see let's go back
so the king on f6 is definitely not
looking good for us
now our idea
let's say um
so we were just we were just looking at
king f6 we looked at king f8
so let's look at bishop c2
it's a trick question yes
yes it was a trick question i just
wanted to see if you guys were looking
for it
so rook g3 zugzwing so it looks like the
only move
uh well not not the only move maybe i
can do this move too
right what would be wrong with with rook
g3 why is it this zugswang
bishop where c2 bishop c2
you haven't really undone black's dream
position black actually it was able to
establish it just in time
so why this position that we said was
wang why can't black just go bishop e4
right unlike with the bishop on b1 if
you go rook g5 i still have a check
what's the problem rook e3
and uh let's say i give a check
i'm getting ready to
the bishop's too close right and if you
go here then h5
and you lose so
the end game is all about domination
of the bishop right this bishop has
it's like like sort of goldilocks you
know it just it needs that that
soup to be just right and the only
square that's just right for the bishop
is c2 so
just like when we see a king on f6 it
should raise a red flag for us when we
see this bishop on any square rather
than
than c2 immediately we should think okay
this is my window of opportunity
so for example b1 d1 e2 e4 these are all
problem squares now the only square
that's decent for the bishop besides c2
is d3 and that's why rook g3 is such an
important move it takes away the only
good remaining square for the bishop
so okay let's see
so we're looking at king h5
we know that bishop e4 doesn't work
simply because of king g5
we don't have to put the rook on g3
we're just going to get the king out
anyway um we know bishop c2 leads to
zugzwang after rook g3
we know bishop e2 well we don't know
bishop e2
this is actually the the only move that
we have left the only idea
that we have left for black
so what do we do
only move right i mean we have to play
this move because if we go here then the
position just gets repeated
so king g5 and of course now black goes
king g7 the difference
on e2 is that you know you can't get hit
with king f4
the bishop is on the wrong diagonal yes
okay rook g3
right because what would have been wrong
if rook c1
or something
right the problem is the bishop just
goes back to the diagonal it wants right
we're not dominating the bishop at all
if kha maybe you're giving me a chance
to keep your bishop
out of the game or or maybe actually
here i could go king h6
first or yeah now i wanted to go here so
i could go king g6 which looks like a
much
better move but uh in any case i think
yeah rook t3 looks uh
looks like a good move uh is that enough
though
right yeah rook g3 what if i go here and
try to make my way back this way
it's so important for the bishop to get
to control these two squares
so just because it's on this diagonal
doesn't quite mean that it's going to
get either to either one
so anybody thinking about anything
what's the first move that comes to mind
yes and what's the problem where does
the bishop go
okay let's try this and
uh i guess we go here
only move
and now i suppose is it king g6 i'm
trying to remember
uh
maybe it's king because if i go
here
white has a threat in these positions
and it doesn't have anything to do with
rook c8 it has everything to do with
getting the pawn to h7
so the only time that you will move this
pawn
is after you've guaranteed that it can
get to h7
because then your king goes to h6 and
it's not stalemate anymore because
when left plays bishop g8 you just take
it right
so for example if black goes bishop b3
now it's over right just
h5 i think
isn't it bishop here
threatening check right if i go here you
have check still
so that's that's no good this is a
this is a draw now right here or
whatever
so king h6 if i go h5 bishop h7
h6 bishop g8 king oh
does that work i don't think so all
right h5 here
here if you do this then i win because
h7 comes
but if you just play your bishop
anywhere else this is a draw
i can't get to g6 and that means i can't
get to play h7
so draw so let's see here
because i only analyzed the move bishop
f7
in that position but it should be very
similar
to bishop g8 so let's see after bishop
f7 here king g8
and now h5 bishop moves king g6
threatening mate
and threatening h6 h7 as well
so how can we do that if the bishop goes
to g8 right away
can we do that oh
so wait we were looking at check king h8
right
and now after king g6 bishop b3
what if i throw in this move
here and now here
i'm threatening mate so you have to go
back
and now if i go here
if you go bishop g8 then i go h7 h6
h6 h7 actually so you have to you have
to threaten some kind of check
you have to get on this diagonal how can
you do that
all right and now plenty more where that
came from
so i win that tempo and i prevent you
from giving the check and then
threatening mate
so you go back and i win another tempo
and that's how i
i keep making progress that way
all right i'm learning stuff too that i
didn't i don't know i'm figuring this
out as we go along
uh okay
so that's it that's the end game see it
wasn't so hard
ah pck so anyway let me show you
because you go through all of this and
then you see it happen in a game and
people just go like h4h5 immediately
you're like ah
come on uh it's very frustrating
so let's see
in the game how white messed this up
right so far white's doing a good job
king f8 and now he goes h5 and here the
wind just goes out the window because
now you don't you know
you don't have anything to go on right
because how are you going to get this k
out
so the rook drops back
and now the king makes it to the corner
and it cannot be displaced
so this is a easy draw
right stalemate okay let me show you
another example
let's see um
actually this one happened to me
let's go to the key moment
but this was actually pretty tricky uh
here no
right so i had a tricky end game where
i'm up in exchange
my this should be a draw i think my
opponent makes a couple of mistakes
that allows me to sweep up
some pause and what made this endgame
kind of hard was that well
you know i still have to take down two
more pawns before i can even get to
the position we've been talking about
but i actually managed to get
to get there right here and now one down
and one to go so rook d4
and now d6 and this is where
where it gets tricky
how would you play as black
it seems like we got to get rid of this
d-pawn before we can even start working
on this end game
but in order to get rid of that d-pawn i
think we got to play h4
so i'm kind of torn i'm like i want the
pawn that i don't want to put my pawn on
h4 because i know i'm not going to win
that end game later
right so i remember and you're also when
you get here you're usually very low on
time already so
it's this this cocktail of
bad things that make it almost
impossible to play the same game
you either win this end game without
thinking
or you you just draw it right so it has
to be almost a reflex by the time
you get around to it so i played h4
which turns out to be a mistake
um the key move here
was rook d3 and to try to put white in a
zug's man where he
he will have to go d7
well actually since the pawns on d6 it
takes away some important squares for
the
for the bishop so for example how would
you play
as white
okay bishop h2 and if i go check
you have to go to g1 because if you go
to g3 i take it
and then we know how to win that so
now i go here
or here maybe
or no no this i think this move
is better you're in this weird kind of
almost zugzwang position
right because if you go bishop e5 after
rook oops after rookie 5
you lost your pawn because if you go
bishop h2 which is the only move that
keeps the bishop
on the diagonal right
or no or do i go
here
i think maybe i won't even go for the
pawn i'll just checkmate you
right now you have no moves well you
have king h1
but i can go here and after this i take
it right so this is the idea this is how
you
how you win the pawn without advancing
your own h pawn
you you work on you know mating nets and
zugzwangs
so that white has to either let you take
on d6 or has to play a desperado d7 move
something like that so
almost anywhere
well so here we were looking at bishop
h2 but you're right the problem seems to
be this king right so what if i go king
g2
instead
yeah and now bishop e5
right and now he has and now he has to
go d7 because he has no
no good moves right again if here check
here here i'm forcing you to go bishop
g1
right because now it's never stalemate i
can always waste a move
and you have to play d7 and i'll take it
so for example
well here if you move the bishop
anywhere else it's just mate so you have
to go bishop g1 and i take it
right so this is what where i messed it
up
uh and instead
right back here i played h4
and now it just goes out the window
because what all white needs to do is
play d7 give the pawn away
put the king on h1 and that's it so
bishop h2
here and now i go for the
for the mating net idea but with the
pawn on h4 it's just much weaker so he
goes d7
takes and he plays king h2 and now it's
a draw because there's no way for me to
first force the king over here and then
sort of get my king out
through g5 but
life is fair and
he made the last mistake of the game
right
uh fair to me not to my opponent that's
what i tried
so he goes
uh so far so good
right i i drive the king out of the g h
files
but now i got the problem how am i going
to get this king out of here
and red flag
red flag right never ever go
there you have to always go back stay
close
to g1 and g2 so after he played king f3
what do we do
and after the bishop moves
yeah right we drive the king away and
then
it's easy to promote this pawn and if
bishop e5
desperately trying to gain a tempo here
to get back
yeah here
yes because we already already messed it
up so the pawn is where it's supposed to
be
so we can pretend like we meant to do
that and go kg2 and it's a win
so i got lucky actually it wasn't fair
at all uh
and and i got to win the game it's the
only time i've ever had this
but it was actually very useful to know
the method because
i knew where i messed up but i also knew
how i could try
my best chance to win it right so so how
to drive the king out of the g h files
and eventually that prompted his mistake
and that's how you're
it's never going to be clean it's always
going to be kind of dirty when you play
it in
an over-the-board game so just having
some vague ideas of
of how you can poke around at your
opponent's position is usually going to
be enough
to win the game now if you manage to
play it perfectly then you're going to
feel it's
elated it's one of the greatest feelings
ever when you play a nice smooth end
game so anyway
it's a really tough end game to learn
it's pretty tough to explain it too
but anyway i hope you you guys are
taking something away from this
uh i hope you enjoyed it and that's it
so thanks for coming
[Music]
you